welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast
today's episode begins with some good
news and some feats of strength
we also have a little update about the
nutrition app that we're building
and we've got a link to a survey the
survey allows you to tell us
exactly what you're looking for in a
nutrition app
and it gives you an opportunity to get
on our list of potential beta testers
after that we've got a research roundup
segment where we talk about capsaicin
supplementation for performance
and ketogenic diets for hypertrophy
we've got a coach's corner segment where
we talk about how to navigate
vacations and time away from the gym
we've got a q a segment
that covers a ton of different topics
and we finally get an objective answer
to the question
is greg actually able to squat the
result
may surprise you as always thank you for
listening
and enjoy the show welcome back to the
stronger by science podcast
this is your host eric trexler today i
am joined by a special temporary guest
co-host
his name is greg knuckles greg thanks
for joining me how are you doing
i'm doing well how are you i am doing
well
uh we've got a lot of stuff to get to
today so let's dive right in
and start with some good news i'm going
to kick things off here
it's summertime in the united states
and that means people are rushing to the
beaches and they might even get the idea
to go into the ocean but
as we all know there's a lot of bad
stuff happening in the ocean
there are stingrays jellyfish
sharks and of course there are whales
so you might be a little bit nervous
about getting into the ocean but this
week i have some good news
for swimmers there is uh one threat
in the ocean that might be perceived as
being worse than it really is
uh so i saw a news story and
basically this guy he was a lobster
diver a lobster fisherman over
in massachusetts and
he unfortunately found himself in the
whale
or in the mouth of a whale um a whale
came by a big humpback whale
and decided to uh you know
essentially swallow him and hey he made
it out he's doing just fine
so if you were worried about getting
into the ocean thinking you know if a
whale swallows me i'm in trouble
you might actually be totally fine so
good news for the swimmers out there and
honestly just
a really crazy story and there were like
several eyewitnesses who were just like
yeah i saw the whale come
and uh you know chomp on that guy and uh
and then he came out pretty crazy yeah
you know i
i don't necessarily know that that's
news though uh
that phenomenon was already very well
documented in the documentary film
pinocchio
um so i i thought we
already had a cultural understanding
that that was a thing
well it's always good to get uh
replication and so we have
even more evidence that uh from a
totally independent
research group here that if you get
swallowed by a whale it might be okay
might not be a big deal
good deal all right uh so i have
a couple pieces of good news one uh
there is apparently a new type of
surgical procedure that can be performed
in utero
to reduce the risk of or prevent
paralysis related to spina spina bifida
in infants so spina bifida
is a condition where
um basically the the neural tube doesn't
form
correctly uh and so like nerve tissue
can be exposed
to the intrauterine environment instead
of being enclosed and protected
uh and that can um
often result in paralysis and uh
so apparently this is this is wild to me
um there's a new procedure where they
can go in
and uh like
perform surgery on a fetus
like 20 weeks uh like a 20-week
uh gestated fetus
in utero to
correct some of those spinal tube
abnormalities to prevent
uh spina bifida associated paralysis i
think they started doing the surgery
in 2020 so i think there are just
articles starting to come out about it
now
um you know now that a lot of those
babies have been born
and they've been alive for a little bit
so you can make sure like ah there don't
seem to be any major complications
um but yeah yeah very very cool stuff
um you love to see it so i i have a
kind of i i know more about
fetal development than i should uh so
when i was working on my phd uh
my phd is in human movement science
right and so the department is like
motor learning and uh there's a lot of
concussion
research uh there's a lot of physical
therapy going on
a lot of you know acl reconstruction
research so like
i was a physiology guy in this
department that really wasn't physiology
focused at least not like exercise
physiology so
when you're a phd student you know
sometimes you're kind of on your own and
they're like hey you need to fill your
course schedule with physiology courses
and i was like cool do you have any and
they're like absolutely not
and i'm like okay what what should i do
and they're like you gotta find a
different department
and so then you go to the medical school
you say hey can i take your physiology
they say you know you're not even a med
student
like you can't take our courses so
basically
your department doesn't have the courses
you need but also no department will let
you into their courses
so like i had one extra physiology
credit
that i needed to fill and the only
department i could talk into
accepting me was uh over in the nursing
department
they had a physiology course that was on
fetal development
and uh so yeah i i'm this stuff
i know it backwards and forwards but to
be honest the only thing
that i really took away from it was that
having a baby
is terrifying and uh like we we covered
terratogens
uh like things that can induce uh
what what's the term for it um you know
any kind of pathological
development of the fetus any kind of uh
developmental issue with the fetus uh
teratogens are things like you know if
you have a huge dose of
like i think it's vitamin a during fetal
development at certain points
in in the process it can be really
devastating so a teratogen is something
that basically interferes with
embryonic or fetal development but yeah
so
we just talked about every possible
thing that could go wrong
with embryo and fetal development and i
just walked out of that thing like
i can't believe babies exist like what
are the odds that it can actually go
right
yeah yeah but um but yeah so
the the one that always jumped out at me
is like oh yeah if if you think
you may have gotten pregnant just like
to be
safe and i think this is specifically
related to spina bifida i'm
i'm reaching here because i learned
about this stuff in undergrad
the neural tube forms very early yeah it
forms very early and i i believe
that heat can interfere with it and so
like one of the things that increases
your risk of spina bifida is taking
hot showers within like the first eight
weeks of pregnancy so it's like
hey you you haven't even missed a period
yet but uh
you know just to be safe just don't take
a hot shower
it's like come on everyone takes hot
showers yeah it's like it's like
whatever you do before you know you're
pregnant make sure that you don't take a
hot shower get in a hot tub
drink an alcoholic beverage smoke or
it's like all these lists of things that
like
you cannot know you're pregnant yet and
there's no reason that you would avoid
those things
yeah unless you knew you're pregnant i
certainly can't say i
i empathize with pregnant women because
you know that's not something i will
ever experience but
boy do i have a lot of sympathy for them
because every time i learn something new
about pregnancy or
things leading up to pregnancy i'm just
like
damn dog that sucks yeah
i basically the moral of the story is i
walked out of that course and my big
takeaway was like
it's literally impossible to have a
healthy baby because there are so many
things that can go wrong
and they are all so scary but it's
awesome to see these types of
of advancements and procedures that can
you know they can intervene
and improve outcomes uh for these you
know
fetuses that have issues for sure all
right uh
next i have a bit of news that has been
framed
as good news that i actually think is
quite ominous
so an article from good news network
aiden 10 youth
think gardening is cool and half would
rather visit a garden center than a
nightclub
basically they interviewed a bunch of
young people
aged 18 to 34 um
you know asked them about their vibes
related to gardening
and then just said hey would you rather
visit a garden center or a nightclub
and so you know they're saying 80 have
good vibes about gardening
uh half would rather go to a garden
center center than a nightclub
oh that's so cool like the kids are all
right
less party culture blah blah blah
i think no absolutely not uh
because if you if someone's gardening i
think that's pretty
pretty suspect uh as people know this is
a podcast for strong christian values
firmly anti-dutch firmly anti-marijuana
this story doesn't have anything to do
with the dutch bit just throwing that in
there in case people forgot
uh but yeah why are people gardening
98 of the time is to grow weed uh
and so you know if there's
you you go back half a generation people
are like oh
you know i want to change my mental
state and feel something new
a lot of them were doing cool club drugs
like
mali mdma that's that's good stuff
uh you know i i don't i do
it was made in a lab probably
uh and and this is a pro science podcast
so we're definitely like a pro party
drug podcast
but like weed that's that's dangerous
stuff that's bad stuff that's that's why
people are gardening
um i i think that this bodes pretty
poorly for future generations
i agree
uh okay um last piece of good news the
nested segment within the good news
segment and that is
the road to the stage segment uh
cut still going well hit a new low
as of recording the last podcast
the smallest number that had showed up
on the scale was
250 now it is 248.6
trend weight is down about three pounds
uh since
the last time we recorded um
and in my uh my small win related to
this
is the intervening two weeks between
recording the last podcast and recording
this one
uh was the crazy time of month for mass
writing which is
if i'm going to significantly deviate
from my diet
that's when i'm going to do it uh and i
i stayed on the wagon
and i feel pretty good about that sweet
and you mentioned your trend weight that
you got from
our app that is still in development you
know we're still developing and testing
as we go
um along those lines we do have a survey
related to the app uh do you want to
give a rundown of the the general
purpose and or content of the survey
uh sure so uh we
are we we i believe by the time this
episode has come out we will have sent
this out already
um a survey basically just to ask people
you know do you track your nutrition
have you ever what apps have you used
what have you liked and not liked about
them etc
uh you know mostly just because our app
is still in development we're still in
alpha even though
beta is going to start pretty soon um
and yeah so we we want to make sure
that it meets the needs and expectations
of people who will be using it
so you know at this point
[Laughter]
98 of the feedback has come from us in
the devs
to make an app that
serves our purposes that we really like
um
you know obviously we're not going to be
the only users of it forever
so uh you know we we want to make sure
that it's going to do
the type of stuff that that people would
wanted to do so that's
that's the main purpose of the survey
and it's also
a big announcement it's also to get
an idea of who would be interested in
being a beta tester
we'll probably have between about 100
and 150
total testers in the upcoming closed
beta
so uh yeah if you want to be a beta
tester
um we will be pulling from people who
filled out that survey so if that's
something that that would interest you
uh definitely check it out and very
importantly if you want to be a beta
tester
uh sending a message to us directly will
not
help in any way so make sure you do the
survey that is where we're going for
beta testers
we're not keeping like a running mental
list of all the people who dm us
well sending a message to me isn't going
to help but i i do think messaging
tracks will
will probably increase your odds i
promise it won't we're going straight to
the
the survey list but if you want to fill
out that survey if you're on our email
list you're probably going to get it i
think but
we also have it linked in the show notes
for today's episode so
you know in the bodybuilding world i
mean i've been using tracking apps
on and off since like i don't know 2011
maybe
and i remember there were all these
bodybuilders who everybody back in the
day
used myfitnesspal and everybody was
super annoyed
because they're like this isn't for us
it doesn't have the the types of
functionality that we want
you know as physique athletes
bodybuilders power lifters lifters
in general uh so there's always this
frustration of like
how can you kind of make my fitness pal
work for what we do
even though it's not really built with
our needs in mind
and so one of the reasons we have this
survey is because we want
to very much make sure that this product
is tailored to the people who are going
to use it so we want to know
what features what functions you want so
that we can
uh you know design the product and and
uh you know
build it accordingly we want to make
sure that it's exactly what people want
so we want to make sure it's built
different exactly as the kids would say
yeah so uh if you are interested in kind
of
uh influencing the development of this
product and making sure that it's got
everything you want
be sure to fill out that survey um all
right
greg what about uh what about feats of
strength yes
so i pulled out uh two deadlifting
related feats of strength for this
episode
uh one is sawyer klatt a
19 year old which to be clear that is a
teenager
a teenage usapl lifter uh
deadlifted 363 kilos or 800 pounds
in the gym um
and i mean 800 is a pretty wild number
regardless of context uh but i believe
he's a 105 kilo lifter um
or competes in the 231 class and
if he were to put 800 on the platform he
would be
only the second teenager ever to do so
i didn't realize that how few uh
800 pound deadlifting teenagers there
were there have been so many
like strong young squatters i just
assumed that there were some more
just crazy deadlifters out there uh but
i checked open powerlifting
and uh unless i just set the search
terms wrong
i'm pretty sure the only uh 19 year old
or younger uh to ever pull 800 in a meet
is actually eric lillybridge who pulled
800 on the dot
uh and i'm pretty sure george lehman
also pulled over 800 as a teenager
but didn't do it uh in a meet uh but
anyway
apparently a very small list of uh
teenagers who've deadlifted 800 pounds
and
the only ones coming to mind uh who are
eric lilly bridge
and i think george lehman uh both
significantly
larger than 231 pounds
[Music]
and maybe some slight differences
in uh blood androgen levels as well uh
because sawyer clatt is a usapl lifter
anyway uh very very impressive stuff
kudos to him
uh and hopefully he will put that on the
platform very soon
and then also uh brandon
i assume this is either streagle or
strygal i'm not sure which one
i think in german grammar rules it would
be streagle
um but anyway brandon streagle
uh deadlifted 400 kilos or 881 pounds
in the gym uh he i believe is a
242 lifter um
and if he were he's a 242 junior lifter
uh and he is currently tied
for the uh biggest deadlift
for a 242 junior uh with 865.3
pounds or uh 392 and a half kilos
tied with jamal browner um so if
he were to put 400 on the platform that
would be the biggest
deadlift ever by a junior 242 lifter
once again young guy i believe he's 21
or recently turned 22
so yeah very very strong young
deadlifters props to them uh
both both of these lifts were done in
the gym
but weren't done with straps so they
seem like
numbers that we might be seeing on the
platform soon
and i very much hope we do all right
good stuff so
moving forward i've got a little
research roundup segment
uh talking about a couple nutrition
topics going to talk about
capsaicin supplementation also going to
talk a little bit about ketogenic diets
um before i do that we had some
lingering questions
related to beta alanine from last
episode we we kind of talked about
you know different delivery
systems for beta alanine like sustained
release formulas and things like that
and some people asked uh if
you know if beta alanine would basically
be relatively stable in water
uh i'm no chemist but based on
the few papers i saw it looked like beta
alanine should be relatively stable in
water
like i wouldn't mix it leave it in a hot
car for a month and come back to it but
you know like i i mentioned that my very
lazy strategy for getting in my beta
alanine and my creatine was just to
put it in water in the morning and just
drink it throughout the day
based on what i saw i didn't see
anything that would suggest that's a bad
plan
now some of the creatine will break down
over the day but
you know if you're taking a big old
scoop you know let's say maybe there's
six or seven grams in there with your
creatine monohydrate if it's a big
heaping scoop
if some of that breaks down to
creatinine before you ingest it
no harm done you're still getting plenty
of creatine uh
you know whatever creatinine you're
you're ingesting
it's just gonna come out no big deal so
yeah i still think that's probably a
decent strategy for those who are
interested
and i did have a few people message me
about you know what do you think about
really really high dose beta alanine
supplementation
you know because we talked about how you
know theoretically a lot of the studies
uh to date have probably underdosed it
in the sense that they haven't
fully or even close to fully saturated
muscle carnosine levels
and you know the the answer to that's
challenging you know so i've had people
who email me and say eric what do you
think about eating 60 bananas a day and
i'm like i don't know i've never seen
what happens when somebody
when somebody does that like if you're
trying like novel nutrition strategies
that we don't have research for it's
hard to
to really forecast exactly how that's
going to go well
and we only have case studies for up to
30 bananas a day
right do we uh oh man
i i don't know if they're still doing
this but do you remember
or did you ever come across the vegan
youtubers
durian writer and freely the banana girl
no so their whole their whole big thing
and
and i'm going off of videos i saw from
them when i was in college so i
you know maybe they're eating 40 or 50
bananas a day now but
but back then like one of their big
things was 30 bananas a day
um is there is there a name for that for
that like gomad
is that oh man i i want to say their
website was just like 30 bananas a
day.com
just vamp for a while and i'll i'll try
to to pull up
uh this piece of of web history
yeah well i'm going to go ahead and and
kind of frame
the next uh thing i'm going to talk
about with capsaicin and you can
you can jump in whenever you have banana
related updates but
like i said the beta alanine uh those
are some of the
persisting or lingering questions so i
wanted to at least address
those before i moved on now in this
research roundup i'm going to start by
talking about
capsaicin and i want to put a caveat
here that
capsaicin is one of those supplements
that's kind of on my watch list
it's it's not like the water watch list
where they're like hey we might ban this
any day
but there's like a couple supplements
that i think are intriguing and
interesting but i really can't quite
give them
a confident recommendation yet so like
betaine is one of those i think there's
some
interesting literature related to
betaine but you know i haven't seen
enough
really directly applicable stuff to say
like absolutely go spend money on
betaine
it's gonna go great you know i'm just
not there yet
capsaicin is another one of those things
and uh
there was recently a systematic review
about capsaicin
that that i wanted to uh to kind of
highlight on the show here so
it was a systematic review and it kind
of explored some of the
potential mechanisms by which capsaicin
supplementation might improve
performance and if you're a mass
reader capsaicin is not new to you we've
actually covered it twice so helms
covered it in 2017
in the time period i call the dark ages
that was before i was a co-author of
mass
speaking of the dark ages uh so i'm i'm
cutting back in with
30 bananas a day content i've now done
my research
cool and in the back in the dark ages of
2014
seems to be when this whole thing peaked
uh when i
when i googled 30 bananas a day there
were a lot of
new i guess not news articles like
human interest articles about this big
fad those
that apparently peaked in 2014 i think
they've moved away from the branding
i found some links on old forums from
2013 2014 to to the 30 bananas a day
url now those redirect to
thefrugavorediet.com so
apparently they've moved on from 30
bananas a day to
all all various types of fruit uh 20
bananas and a pineapple yeah which i
mean
in the grand scheme of things probably
probably good
i assume bananas aren't nutritionally
complete
yeah i don't think that they are like a
singular food source that
achieves all needs for human dietary
intake
but yeah they uh that seems to have
peaked around my senior
year of college and uh yeah they've
moved on from that
fair enough but uh but yeah so like i
said capsaicin we covered it in mass in
2017 and then again
in 2019 as more research has come out on
the topic so
the thing that's interesting about
capsaicin is
there are some studies showing
performance benefits
in humans so that's always a good start
and i think the
mechanisms are are really fascinating
they're really compelling so this
systematic review which is linked in the
show notes
uh they talked a little bit about the
various mechanisms that could be at play
and you know without question the main
way that capsaicin's probably doing its
thing
is by binding to a receptor that is
called the
uh it's the trpv1 receptor
which doesn't really roll off the tongue
but
um but that is the the main receptor
that it targets and
you know it could have a number of
effects uh you know
as capsaicin is ingested and ultimately
binds with that receptor so
there is some evidence to suggest that
capsaicin supplementation
could increase calcium release from the
sarcoplasmic reticulum
and so that can be a really helpful
thing uh you know that calcium release
in the sarcoplasmic reticulum
is a critical aspect of muscle
contraction actually
allowing muscles to contract and
generate force
and one of the things we see with
certain supplements that increase that
calcium release
is that they can you know increase
force of muscle contraction especially
during fatigue
you know so during fatigue muscles start
to tire out a little bit if they can get
a little bit of extra calcium released
from the sarcoplasmic reticulum in many
cases
that can delay that fatigue a little bit
and allow muscles to continue creating
force at a high level
uh it could also potentially increase
fatty acid
oxidation which theoretically could make
more energy available for utilization
and uh it's possible another mechanism
is
it could have an analgesic effect so it
can reduce uh
pain perception a little bit or increase
pain tolerance during exercise and
that's
that's one mechanism actually there one
of the things that i find really
interesting
is some of the overlap mechanistically
between capsaicin and caffeine
so like caffeine can affect calcium
kinetics in the sarcoplasmic reticulum
uh caffeine
also can influence uh perceived pain and
perceived exertion during exercise so
that's one of the reasons that i'm
intrigued by this small
but uh but interesting uh body of
literature here
there's also some evidence to suggest
that it could help spare glycogen a
little bit
and it could increase the release of
acetylcholine
during exercise so there are a number of
ways by which
capsaicin could theoretically be a
helpful supplement when it comes to
enhancing performance and theoretically
delaying fatigue now the
uh kind of getting to the highlights or
the conclusion here of this
particular systematic review
they identified 22 relevant studies to
look at so
14 of them looked at the effects of
either capsaicin
capsaicin or related capsaicinoids
14 studies looking at supplementation
and how they
impact performance in animals
of those 14 9 showed
some benefit to performance so
not you know not batting a thousand
there but
more than a fluke you know it's not like
one of those supplements where there's
one or two animal studies so you're a
baseball player you you'd be in
cooperstown
oh both yeah definitely yeah i i think i
think that should be a new
meta analytic technique the uh if it's
over like a 330
yeah the the the cooperstown barrier you
know if it for uh
for for ones that just go with like a uh
like a vote counting approach
where you can't actually meta-analyze it
just be like look man if if you're bad
and better than 330 like
it's definitely good yeah well that
which certainly
really wouldn't be a good metric at all
but uh
i don't know might yeah that that would
actually be really stupid but
i would think it was funny well in this
case 9 out of 14 i mean you're
really you have your own room in the
baseball hall of fame if you're batting
9 out of 14. that almost reduces to a
perfect 5 out of 7.
well there you go um anyway so yeah
there were 22 studies like i said 14
were in animal models
9 out of 14 showed some degree of
benefit um
there were eight studies looking at
performance in humans
and uh three demonstrated
significant acute benefits for
performance
for endurance performance and then uh
two also reported uh
acute benefits for resistance exercise
performance so
uh not bad you know eight studies three
showing
uh benefits for endurance two showing
benefits for uh resistance
training performance so it is you know
there's a collection of interesting
mechanisms that seem pretty plausible
there are some
emerging uh positive findings so like i
said this is kind of on my list of
supplements that i'm
interested in not quite ready to say
that they're going to be
beneficial something to keep in mind of
course it's a very small body of
literature and one of the things that's
common with small bodies of literature
is
you know if there's only like three or
four studies on a topic in humans a lot
of times
half of them or more are going to be
from the same lab group they're like the
first people who said hey we want to do
this
and so that's very much the case with
capsaicin a lot of the the research
comes from
you know the same lab group and the same
kind of
group of collaborators which is not a
bad thing but with any
with any body of research you always
want to see that it replicates in
different lab groups different regions
you know different scenarios you want to
make sure that the finding is robust and
generalizable across the board
uh so so that's where we find ourselves
with capsaicin and
i think one of the things that uh
people are likely to wonder is
you know this is interesting i don't
necessarily want to shell out on a
supplement
uh it's not a really common supplement
that i can just kind of you know
go down to the grocery store and find it
next to the protein bars
so why don't i just get capsaicin or or
capsaicinoids from my food
and the the challenge there is you know
some of the dosa or some of the dosing
guidelines
when you look at the studies that have
ergogenic benefits in humans
talking about one or two 12 milligram
doses
of usually a purified capsid powder
so it's a capsaicinoid
the studies that have used like high
high-dose capsaicin
itself or like big doses of just like
cayenne pepper or something like that
a lot of times they do report a pretty
notable gastrointestinal
discomfort and so that's
probably not what you want to do uh you
know if you have a
really really really spicy meal um
before a workout
yeah you can probably get plenty of
capsaicinoids uh
i i was looking into it and it looks
like average daily capsaicin intake in
europe is roughly 1.5 milligrams per day
based on the resource i found
uh once again the ergogenic dose is like
one or two
12 milligram doses
so 1.5 milligrams a day is is pretty
common throughout europe
but it looked like in india and mexico
sometimes you
you'd find intakes in the range of 25 to
200 milligrams per day
which is that's a lot of capsaicin 200
milligrams is a lot
that's a that's a lot of uh vindaloo
chicken
yeah but uh but anyway uh so i i don't
think you know
i usually like to promote getting stuff
from food whenever
possible because it's convenient and
usually
you end up bringing in all sorts of
other good stuff along with the active
ingredient but
when it comes to capsaicin as a
pre-workout supplement it's probably not
a great idea
your mouth might be on fire your stomach
might be burning during the workout
the gi related complications might not
be
might not be advisable when we're
talking about trying to get a small
performance benefit having an upset
stomach throughout your workout is going
to be a net negative
uh i would think all right dumb dumb
question
this is a supplement uh segment which
means i'm gonna have stupid questions at
the end of it
okay so uh throughout this you've been
talking about capsaicin and
capsaicinoids uh
my my understanding of this which i've
purely derived from conversations with
you is that other capsaicinoids
seem to have similar physiological
effects to capsaicin but aren't spicy
right uh yeah they so like capsi8
is the one that you find in a lot of the
supplement trials and i
i don't think it's spicy if it is spicy
i would expect that it's way less spicy
than capsaicin itself
okay and and does that cause
does that also cause like the gi
distress issues
i would assume no i don't think so no
the the capsi
studies look pretty good okay in terms
of the the
lack of gi uh symptoms it's usually the
capsaicin itself
or a you know like i said a just
straight-up cayenne pepper
that's usually where you see it so i'm
wondering if it would be
feasible to consume ergogenic amounts of
capsiate from
a non-crazy amount
of like bell pepper ingestion or
something like that because
i mean dude just like a green bell
pepper or like a red bell pepper
remove the core cut it into strips
that's that's some of the best snacking
you can do oh i love bell peppers yeah i
used to eat them all the time i need to
get back into bell peppers
peppers are good stuff i kind of forgot
they exist oh i know why i forgot about
them because you have to cut them
and like wash them you don't you you
kind of do
no you can eat you can eat it like an
apple yeah
just as you're going around the top you
just take small enough bites that you're
not actually biting into the core
and the thing is want to like collapse
though uh so
what i what i do if i'm just going to
eat a whole bell pepper
maybe i'm sharing too much information
here is i'll just kind of like
nibble around the top right and so
let's listen it's like a little hamster
but it's fine like
it's actually really cool everyone all
the cool kids are doing it so you nibble
around the top
and from there you can just pull the
bottom off and like the
the core and the stem stick with like
the top
part so that that oh yeah i see what
you're saying so yeah you eat around the
top
you've isolated all of the waste
products
and then you can just eat the bottom
like an apple like you you can cut it up
but you you don't need to sweet
okay yeah i'd have to look into how much
capsiate
is is in some of those different types
of peppers out there
but um one thing i did find looking
through the capsaicin research
is there was a study in 2019 that looked
at
in a rigorous evidence-based manner
looked at what kinds of beverages
were helpful for uh extinguishing
the very unpleasant spicy food taste you
know like the discomfort
that that comes when you eat something
that's just a little bit too spicy
and so no surprise they looked at a
bunch of different beverages
no surprise that whole milk and skill
and skim milk
did pretty well that's kind of the
classic beverage that a lot of people
know to turn to
is going for milk but a surprise
contender
a dark horse candidate that really uh
really outperformed its reputation was
kool-aid
kool-aid did quite well i forget what
flavor i think they went with like the
red
flavor in this study but uh but yeah so
it
if you are having some spicy foods and
you're like okay this is unbearable i
need something
milk always a good choice uh kool-aid
also a good contender there oh yeah
perfect that that's excellent uh
so i i will personally never drink
kool-aid again uh i'm out of the
kool-aid game so
when i was in high school there was this
really
really intense wrestling camp not too
far away
uh and we would go up there and like it
was like you'd wake up
run it run a couple miles and then you'd
have like three practices a day
and then you'd sleep on the mats like
you did not it was in like a barn
and like you did not leave the barn yeah
and it
the amenities were as you could
anticipate not great right so breakfast
was like dry cereal
lunch was like you know some
sandwiches on like wonder bread
but basically the only beverage that you
consume the entire time you're there was
kool-aid
and the reason was it was in the middle
of nowhere
and it was on like you know well water
and it was not
this was not good well water i i think
they should have brought in
someone to maybe do and expect an
inspection of the well
i don't think the water coming out was
great didn't smell great
they basically put the kool-aid in to
make it palatable enough to consume
on like you know you can imagine you're
in a room with no air conditioning
middle of july three practices a day we
needed to drink like six gallons of
water a day
yeah yeah and without the kool-aid in
there it simply wasn't drinkable
yeah they did some economic calculations
and realized that kool-aid is actually
cheaper than water softener yeah
no like it was it was like that but yeah
so it's almost like uh
anyone who's gone through a phase of
drinking screwdrivers you know like
vodka and orange juice you like can't
drink orange juice anymore after that
you have like phantom tastes of the
vodka and it just grosses you out
yeah yeah uh that's how i am with
kool-aid i can like taste the sulfur in
kool-aid even if it's not there
it was so disgusting it's like just like
sulfur and iron and stuff
but yeah anyway yeah no more kool-aid
for me but
it's still a good choice uh okay moving
on i want to talk about
keto really quickly uh so
there were actually a couple
meta-analyses that came
out recently looking at the effects of
ketogenic diets on lean mass so
i'll link both of them in the show notes
um
but uh basically the results were not
particularly surprising if you've been
staying up to date with the
the the research on keto specifically
when it comes to
gaining muscle right so there have been
a few studies lately that we've covered
in mass about uh
you know ketogenic diets for the purpose
of gaining muscle rather than using it
as a weight loss intervention
and so both of these meta-analyses
pretty much ended up pointing in the
same direction which is that
when people go on these ketogenic diets
and they're lifting
um a lot of times we do observe
reductions in body weight whether
it's supposed to happen or not a lot of
times we see reductions
in fat mass and body fat percentage but
the
non-ketogenic comparator diets tend to
do a little bit
better when it comes to gains in lean
body mass and sometimes
gains in uh different strength and power
outcomes so
uh one of the meta-analyses here uh
the title was effects of resistance
training combined with a ketogenic diet
on body composition
a systematic review and meta-analysis
just looking through they found 13
randomized controlled trials with 244
participants that met their inclusion
criteria
so uh the ketogenic diet significantly
uh decreased body mass the
weighted mean difference ended up being
about three and a half kilograms
uh so there was a significant reduction
in fat mass a little over two kilograms
uh you know significant reduction in
body fat percentage of about
two two and a half percentage points
compared to a non-ketogenic
comparator diet but the fat free mass
there was also a significant reduction
of about
one and a quarter kilograms and so like
i said uh we've gone through a few
studies recently in mass looking at
ketogenic diets that were specifically
either given in uh the intention of the
trial was not to lose weight
it was either to keep people pretty
close to maintenance or even
induce a caloric surplus trying to put
on some muscle and strength
and what we see with these ketogenic
diets in these trials is
a lot of times the ketogenic group just
can't help but lose fat and so
you know one of the things there's two
things that are kind of
at play there i suspect that that quote
is going to get clipped
and is going to cause you headaches in
the future what did i say
uh people who do ketogenic diets just
can't help but lose fat
oh god yeah well it made sense in the
context i was using it
because it's you know the trials were
not intended to be weight loss trials
but they lost weight
yeah you know so like it happened
i i'm i'm just saying that's gonna get
clipped and your life is over
yeah well i mean that'll be nice though
because
the then i'll be like a god in the
ketogenic world
and every time i write about keto they
act like i hate keto so
maybe it'll earn me some some good uh
some good vibes over in the keto
universe
good luck but uh but anyway you know so
basically these studies they're they're
trying to
build muscle and gain some weight and a
lot of times we'll see that the
ketogenic group
either fails to gain weight or in some
cases even loses a little bit
because the ketogenic diet like it has a
pretty well-known effect on you know
reducing appetite and from
a n equals one practical perspective
i've done
a ketogenic diet for somewhere in the
ballpark of like six to nine months
straight
and i certainly noticed that my appetite
was quite lower
compared to similar calorie intake on a
more
moderate macronutrient distribution so
it's a thing that happens reduced
appetite and so
if you're trying to lose fat that can be
a really positive thing
uh no question but if you're trying to
bulk on a ketogenic diet it can be
something that makes the process a
little bit more challenging
uh another thing i noticed on the
ketogenic diet was that
i just didn't want to eat as much
because i the food choices were really
limited and i was like
hmm am i ready for another round of
ground beef and broccoli
and at a certain point i was like i'm
just tired of these foods
and so i reduced my intake because i was
just like i'd rather not eat than
eat these same foods again to be honest
so that's a me thing that's not it
wouldn't be fair to
necessarily criticize the diet for that
but i mean it certainly
at least generalizes to the opposite
side of the table here
yeah you found the same thing oh
absolutely
yeah i was like i'm not gonna eat like a
stick of butter so
i guess i'm just not gonna eat yeah yeah
um
but uh but so so those things could be
playing into it of course when you look
at these types of studies you have to
also acknowledge the fact that
these studies almost exclusively use
body comp devices that cannot truly
account for
the loss of glycogen and the reductions
in water weight that come with that so
when we've talked about these studies in
mass as we're reviewing the research we
always acknowledge like oh
you know the keto group was you know
this many kilograms
off in terms of lean body mass you know
maybe they
uh you know the the uh
control group or you know the non-keto
group gained two and a half kilos of
lean mass and the keto group only gained
a half
you know there might be a gap between
them that's one and a half two two and a
half kilograms
and so then the challenge there with
interpretation is saying okay
what is the most likely number we can
insert there
if we're going to assume that this is
water weight you know and in some of my
articles i've kind of run through my
justification
for what estimate i think is appropriate
for that
uh so so there's the appetite reduction
thing
there's the palatability thing that
could come into play
and of course there's the fact that if
you're on a ketogenic diet
uh glycogen is is probably going to be
lower
in muscle and uh that could take some
water weight with it
now whenever i bring that up people
always point me to a study by
volek and colleagues suggesting that
actually
people on keto for a long time their
their glycogen levels and their glycogen
utilization during exercise
well i shouldn't say utilization i'd
have to double check that
but they basically found that glycogen
levels uh were very similar at baseline
i think they were looking specifically
at muscle glycogen in the figure
figure that's in my head right now um
but the majority of research uh
looking at keto adapted folks who have
been on
on the diet for some time generally
shows lower muscle glycogen levels
uh than non-keto folks so
i definitely would not hang my hat on
that finding like a lot of people have
lately
but anyway when it comes to keto um
like i said greg every time i write
about it people are like oh dude you're
way too tough
on ketogenic diets i really don't think
i am uh
i i think i do a terrific job i'm
kidding
uh no like i think a ketogenic diet
there there's a time and a place for it
like if you tell me like hey i'm on a
ketogenic diet because i'm trying to
lose some fat
and i really struggle with a really
ravenous
appetite and it fits my food preferences
better and i've really thought out the
design of my diet i've got all my bases
covered it's a well-constructed diet
of course like that that is completely
fine there's no reason to say that it
can't be a viable option in that
scenario
uh if you're an ultra ultra endurance
athlete and you're like dude i do these
like
really low intensity things for
extremely long durations and i just
prefer a ketogenic diet
um you know i i don't see much of a
problem with that either i don't think
it
some people kind of frame it as this
like complete game changer where like if
you're an ultra endurance athlete who's
not
on keto that you're just you know you're
going to fall behind the pack i don't
think i buy into that
but but if you're doing a form of
exercise that truly has minimal
high-intensity efforts or like if you're
a
or if it's the opposite and it's only
very high intensity efforts like
if you're a power lifter who already
thinks anything over three reps is
cardio
yeah you're probably fine yeah yeah i
mean if yeah
and that's another thing is um you know
sometimes i'll
i'll write about keto and i'll have that
i'll somebody'll be like dude i'm on
keto and it's
been going great like i haven't seen any
drops in performance
i'm like right but you only do doubles
and triples
like you've you've never touched
glycogen in your life it's like
phosphocreatine during your sets and
then you're just kind of
aerobically replenishing
phospho-creatine stores
between sets so yeah you're good
so yeah i mean like i'm not anti-keto
it's just like you know every now and
then
i'll talk to people who it's like yeah
you know i do a fair bit of cardio
uh you know a lot of my resistance
training right down the middle sets it
eight to twelve sometimes up to fifteen
and i'm like i just feel like you'd be
better off with some carbs in your life
you know if if you're trying to squeeze
every last drop out of your training
um but you know not everybody has to so
that's another thing to keep in mind
like
when we write articles about like how to
optimize nutrition for training
the assumption baked in there is that
you wish to optimize it
but like dude like a lot of times i
train fasted
uh and i don't think it's optimal like
i've talked about like my
my recommendations for pre-workout
nutrition but sometimes i just want to
roll out of bed and get my workout in
because i don't want to skip it
and if i don't do it first thing in the
morning i'm going to skip it sometimes
if i know what my my calendar is looking
like that day so like dude
i mean greg i'm sure that you can say
the same but
i have a very impressive track record of
doing sub-optimal things
but like it's fine you know not
everything has to be optimized the
important thing is
identifying what is optimal and then
deciding if if you wish to do that or
not
uh so yeah i mean i have no interest in
talking people out of keto but
i think when you look at the research on
specifically trying to utilize ketogenic
diets
for bulking for building muscle and
adding lean mass it just doesn't seem
like
like the best option out there doesn't
mean it can't be
done so again people are going to say
well i did keto and i gained
you know six pounds of muscle and that
that's terrific and and
you know there's nothing wrong with that
but might have been a path of lesser
resistance had you
gone with a more moderate macronutrient
distribution
so yeah that's basically this
meta-analysis lines up pretty well with
the last couple times we've looked at it
in mass which just indicates that
it's viable but but probably not optimal
for muscle gains
uh you know for a bulking diet dude
i'm just thinking about the logistics of
being in a surplus on a ketogenic diet
because like i was trying to uh
gradually lose weight when i did keto
and i ended up losing weight
pretty quickly due to what we talked
about before like
yeah i really just don't want to eat
another serving of like fatty ground
beef or like
you know if i want to have uh say
chicken thighs like i need to add extra
fat to it to
to stay in ketosis or whatever like
dude that was tough enough when i was
trying to be in a small deficit
if i was trying to be in like uh two
three
four hundred calorie per day surplus
forget about it dude
like i that that makes these research
findings
so incredibly understandable because i'm
just thinking like man
for myself for a week or two adherence
would be fine and then after that i'd be
like
dude [ __ ] science like i don't like
these researchers that much
like i'm just not gonna eat that much
yeah another thing logistically so if
you think about it if you're tracking
your
let's say you're using some oil to get
your calories up
and you're you're weighing it right so
you have like a little wing
container on your scale and you pour the
oil in
and then you're going to cook something
on a pan with it and then you transfer
it from the measuring cup
into the pan
[Music]
i think a lot of people lose calories on
ketogenic diets
because there's a little residual oil in
the measuring cup and then there's a
little residual oil in the pan
unless you're licking the pan clean when
you're done i think
people also one of the things that makes
it challenging with
uh with bulking is there's the appetite
thing
there's the food selection thing but
there's also i i think uh
i know it it sounds like overly um
obsessive about the details but i if
if you're doing that for several meals a
day you
could actually be taking in quite a few
fewer calories than you thought
in my opinion uh perhaps i sound like
like an idiot there but
no i i think that's plausible i mean if
you
if you just look and see what like four
grams of olive oil looks like
it's not that's not much olive oil right
like yeah you could you could have a
little bit
left behind in a container and a pan on
your plate
in your bowl yeah and uh you know
if if there's like a pretty good bit of
fat in each meal
i don't think it's completely
unreasonable that you could lose
10 grams of fat between the pan the
plate and the
the measuring vessel each meal and that
adds up to
yeah 90 calories a meal yeah if you eat
like
four meals a day that's like 350 360
calories a day like that
that seems pretty plausible to me yeah
so anyway i i don't uh
i i i certainly would never indicate
that you can't
build muscle on a ketogenic diet but
that would be a non-evidence-based
uh perspective in my opinion um but i
think when we compare it to
a more moderate macronutrient
distribution it just doesn't seem to be
the optimal way to go
so you can certainly uh make some
progress with it but
unless you're really adamant about keto
if you come to me and say hey eric i
want to bulk up i want to really put on
some
some muscle mass here i want to gain
some weight uh
keto would not be my first choice um
but you know it it's certainly an option
out there and if you really like it then
honestly i'm not saying this to be a
smart ass i think it's terrific you know
finding a diet that works for you
is important and it's okay
that different people are on different
diets um all right so greg
let's see what's uh what's up next here
uh we got a coach's corner
getting into the corner getting very
practical uh
let's see what you got yeah so uh
it's summertime baby mid-june um
you know what weather's good northern
hemisphere this is the time people start
going on vacation
a lot of people go early june
a lot of people try to get out of town
for fourth of july in
the us people might have some trips
planned later in the summer
whatever this is summer vacation time
and so uh i've been getting
a lot of questions about like oh hey i'm
i'm doing one of your programs and i'm
going on vacation this week like what
should i do about it
um and just a lot of general chatter
like oh
i'm going on a vacation for a week how
how do i avoid losing my gains
and so uh yeah just just want to do a
coach's corner about
vacations and taking uh
taking a little bit of time away from
training not due to injury
kind of more generally um so
okay let's say you're
you know you're someone you you've built
a lot of muscle
you've built a lot of strength uh and
you
want to try to uh not kind of lose where
you are in a program so you can jump
right
right back in after a trip uh but you're
going with your family
and you don't want to sneak away to a
gym two hours a day
every day on your vacation one good for
you
people who do that absolutely insane no
judgment if you do
but a little bit like you're on vacation
dude just enjoy it
um so okay if you're not going to the
gym every day on vacation
and you definitely want to try to
maintain everything you have and you
uh feel like you can't you know maybe
you exercise just for
for mental health it makes you feel good
or maybe you just feel like you need to
do
a little bit of something what should
you do uh body weight training
works great we talked about this at the
start of the pandemic when gyms closed
like
the variety of exercises you can do
without a gym to continue training all
major muscle groups of your body
people who are um
you know people who've pretty much
exclusively done
gym workouts for a long time you know
maybe haven't thought that much
about body weight training and
how you can target various muscle groups
with just body weight or with very
minimal equipment
uh there's a there's a good article on
stronger by science that basically just
goes through and lists like hey you know
you're trying to train your shoulders
here are some options
you're trying to train your hamstrings
here are some options
uh if you get just like a a
basic set of resistance bands and you
have your body weight
you're set you can train anything you
know
and uh take 20 30 minutes a day
hit most of your major muscle groups
you'll be fine um
so yeah if you want to keep training on
vacation
you can accomplish a lot with just body
weight training or with
body weight training and a set of
resistance bands
okay so uh moving on a popular idea that
i see
bandied about is like hey you know i'm
going on vacation
um i i'm not planning on training while
i'm there
not going to the gym not you know i
don't want to do any bodyweight training
it's just going to be chill vibes the
whole time
so maybe what i should do is
intentionally overreach in the week or
two leading up to my vacation
so during that week that i'm not
training i'll super compensate and come
back
bigger and stronger than ever before
basically intentionally overreach
such that your body will be recovering
and super compensating
the whole time you're on vacation so
that that's an idea that i see bandied
around a bit
um and there is some degree of evidence
that it could
actually be a thing so i i wrote an
article
uh in mass a couple years ago about a
study by bjornsson
looking at delayed hypertrophic super
compensation um
that that was an idea that i'd seen
suggested before
but uh the the bjornssen study was the
first
uh empirical evidence that that i'd seen
uh that convincingly
demonstrated that it could exist we
republish that article on stronger by
science that'll be linked in the show
notes if you would like to read it
uh so there might be something to this
concept physiologically but
uh just to throw a little bit of cold
water on this idea
one the observed hypertrophic
supercompensation
in the bjornsen study was only observed
on the muscle fiber level
so after uh cessation of training
they saw that type 1 and type 2 muscle
fibers continued to
increase in cross-sectional area for
several days
after the end of the training period
that actually wasn't observed
with whole muscle size though um so
there
you go it could have just been like
various things offsetting so
you stop training maybe you get a slight
decrease in muscle edema
but you also get a slight increase in
fiber cross-sectional area
kind of balances out when you're talking
about whole muscle size but yeah
theoretically it's a net positive um but
anyway
it's it's probably not going to show up
in terms of like
huge visual changes um
two the subjects were untrained so
you know a little bit easier to
intentionally overreach
uh if you're untrained than if you're
well trained so
you know who knows how how much you
would have to ramp up your training
to uh induce a similar effect
you know if you've been training
consistently for a few years
uh and two or in three the the training
protocol they used in that study
was uh was pretty brutal
even if they weren't using untrained
lifters so
uh it involved two blocks
two five day blocks of training with
seven workouts per day
so uh they were looking at delayed
hypertrophic super compensation
uh after you know after the end of
training after the second block in the
second block
uh people are training their quads once
per day
four sets to failure for three days and
then twice per day
four sets to failure for two days so
seven workouts over five days
and the last two days they were doing
two a days all sets taken to failure um
and that that induced enough
overreaching that they saw
some uh subsequent delayed fiber
hypertrophy
i assume you're not gonna be doing
something similar with all muscle groups
of your body
prior to vacation if you are more power
to you but uh
yeah that's that's a that's a pretty
rough training protocol
so in my opinion there might be some
degree of physiological rationale for
this idea but to me the risk to reward
ratio just doesn't make
much sense um you know because if you're
intentionally
overreaching you're probably
opening yourself up to some degree of
increased injury risk
uh and last thing you want to do is be
like ah yeah i'm taking
taking a week at the beach i'm gonna
hang out
vibe oh no like i i sustained a
serious sprain or strain uh right before
i left and so now
uh instead of chilling and vibing i'm
just
in pain the whole time and hobbling
around so
you know i i wouldn't recommend that
approach
but uh theoretically there's some degree
of rationale for it but again
i personally do not recommend it my
recommended approach if you're going on
vacation
it's just it's just chill out man uh
or or a woman um like
if you're training pretty hard pretty
consistently year round
i think a lot of people so i i think a
lot of people
won't have a inclination to keep
exercising on vacation or to
push themselves extra hard with exercise
before vacation
because they're afraid they're gonna
lose
a substantial amount of the progress
they've made
if they allow themselves just to rest
and relax
um some some people like i mentioned
before maybe just
exercise every day it's become a habit
solely because it makes you feel good
and there's
um you know those other
factors i just talked about not really a
big thing you're not necessarily doing
it because you're afraid you'll lose
some muscle you just do it because you
like it if that's the case
very cool more power to you but if there
is that kind of
level of neuroticism like i've worked so
hard for this
i can't i can't relax for a week because
i feel like
it's going to slip away from me to some
substantial degree
you just don't need to worry about that
one week off
isn't going to substantially affect
anything that you've worked towards um
a week away from training isn't enough
time to
substantially lose any strength if
anything you might come back stronger
just because
you're you're dropping your fatigue
you're going to be rested and recovered
and if strength is a little bit lower
when you get back to training
it's not because you're actually weaker
like you're just gonna need to take a
week to
to dust some rust off and then you'll be
fine uh
and also a week away isn't enough time
to lose
any appreciable degree of muscle at all
um something that people will
occasionally
discuss is like oh man i was out of the
gym for a week and i just feel like
my muscles look smaller feel smaller
there there might be some degree of
truth to that but it's not
actual loss of contractile tissue uh if
you're training pretty hard pretty
consistently
you probably have at least some small
degree of muscle edema
at all times like your muscles are
slightly swollen
um and if you're consistently exercising
pretty hard and and have a fair bit of
carbohydrate in your diet
exercise allows you to store slightly
higher levels of glycogen in your
muscles which
again more fluid storage might
make them appear slightly larger and
more pumped
so you know you take a week away from
training uh
you're not exercising those muscles the
same way
maybe a little bit of inflammation goes
down and yeah
you know after a week out of the gym
your muscles might look a little smaller
but don't worry you haven't lost muscle
all of the contractile tissue is still
there
uh it's it's purely those those fluid
shifts
and uh you know as soon as you start
training again
uh all of that visual appearance of
muscle
is gonna come back pretty much
immediately so
if you're if you feel the need to train
because you think
you're going to lose strength lose
muscle with a week out of the gym
you just don't need to worry about it it
will be perfectly fine
and then the last thing i want to say on
the topic is if you do
as i recommend and just take a week off
enjoy yourself
vibe have a good time um
first week back in the gym it's not a
terrible idea
to dial things back a little bit to ease
yourself back into training
um so you know it shouldn't be super
super easy but
uh don't go in like planning to hit big
pr's
that's a mistake i see uh especially
especially some strength athletes make
they're like ooh
i'm gonna basically treat this as if i
was tapering for a meat
um like you know i might the only other
time that i might take a week off of
heavy training is when i'm peeking for a
meet so
i'm gonna treat vacation the same way
and first session back
uh you know i'm gonna see what this d
load has done for me and try to hit
something really heavy
go for some prs i wouldn't recommend
that
um you know unless you do happen to have
a meet
on the saturday after your vacation um
in general for that first week back in
training uh not a bad idea to
to ease yourself back in somewhat gently
so
you know maybe drop a set per exercise
maybe decrease loads by about five
percent maybe stop
one or two reps further from failure
than you typically would
we're not talking major major training
alterations just
take everything down half a step
uh you know just to re-acclimate to the
gym
uh re-expose your tissues to load and
then that second week back
you know go ham train as you typically
would
uh so that that's how i would recommend
uh approaching time off
yeah you know i've done really all of
these approaches
uh you know i've had vacations where i i
find a local gym
i just continue my training as normal
just because i
was having fun with my training at the
time and i was like oh
i'd love to have fun you know five very
fun workouts while i'm on vacation so i
can definitely relate to that
uh i've also done uh the
you know the the approach to train
really hard the week leading into it
yeah so then you know you kind of take
that week off because you really at that
point need
a week off i've done you know modified
training where i do body weight and band
stuff and then of course i've also taken
full weeks off so
you know each approach there's a time
and a place there are pros and cons but
i did have
a question for you which is you know you
kind of
had this whole topic the assumption
baked into it
was that vacation is one week long what
is the duration
at which point you would say okay let's
at least do some bodyweight and band
stuff if we're gonna be away for
you know this long i'd say if you're
going longer than two weeks
uh probably not a bad idea to
go into it with the intention that
you're gonna do
at least a little bit of something along
the way i i think i think
up to two weeks is pretty safe to just
you know not worry about it and just
relax
if you're you know if you're taking a
month-long trip somewhere
that that probably is enough time to
lose a meaningful amount of muscle mass
um
so yeah yeah if if it's like a pretty
long trip
you know that's that that then uh
like bodyweight training or like trying
to find a gym
along the way to maybe get in like one
weekly workout
uh that might be start becoming more of
a consideration
yeah and you know you don't have to do
much you know so
if you're gonna be somewhere for three
weeks or four weeks
and you're like you know what i i don't
want to lose a bunch of gains but i also
don't want to spend my whole vacation in
the gym
right you know there's research that you
could do a third of your volume
uh maybe even as little as like a ninth
of your volume
uh and as long as you're keeping the
intensity high you should be able to
maintain a decent amount of
of what you've gained so you don't have
to go in and do
full volume workouts you can really
streamline things
as long as you're getting after it you
should be able to maintain pretty well
so you know that like i said that only
applies for
for the longer term thing but i would
say
don't delude yourself into thinking that
a nutritional intervention is gonna fix
this
so that that's one thing a lot of people
do is they say like oh no it's fine i
was out of the gym for six weeks but
like i ate a lot of protein
and like that is not gonna save you in
this scenario same you know
same it's not like protein
supplementation or branch chain amino
acid supplementation it's just not going
to get the job done it's either training
or no training you're either providing
the stimulus or you're not so
you know make an informed decision about
how you want to approach it but don't
trick yourself into thinking that
there's kind of a nutritional hack
that can make up for being out of the
gym for four five six weeks
yeah and one one thing i just want to
circle back on i think i probably
uh came in a bit too hot
insofar as it relates to uh
people going to the gym while they're on
vacation my
my assumption is that like you know
families are going on vacation or maybe
you're going on vacation with a partner
who's maybe not
as into training as you are and
you know you don't need those people in
your life time yeah
the assumption i was working with is
basically like time spent in the gym is
time
spent away from the vacation and the
people you're vacationing with
if you're just going on vacation by
yourself and you love the gym
and that's like something that
that gets you those good chill vibes or
if you're going on vacation with someone
else who's just as into the gym as you
are
or if you had time carved out where it's
like ah people are gonna go their
separate ways like
some people are gonna lay out on the
beach some people are gonna go shopping
and you're like yeah i want to go to the
gym at this time like
that's totally cool i i think i came
across more judgmental
than i meant to um i i've definitely
worked out
on vacation and in fact i've uh
previously used vacations um
partially as excuses to visit gyms that
i
that i thought looked cool that i'd
wanted to train at so
yeah i went to orlando a few years ago
uh
checked out orlando barbell brian
schwab's gym who's super cool
when i was up in philly a few years ago
um
worked out at iron sport gym uh right
there outside of philly
uh so yeah i mean
you know basically if you're on vacation
it should be a vacation
and if uh if you go into the gym doesn't
detract from the vacation and that's
something that is good vacation vibes
for you not gonna [ __ ] up the trip for
anyone else
cool go for it uh i i feel like i came
across
as somewhat judgmental about that and i
i did not intend to but basically if
you're going to the gym for good chill
vacation vibes
sweet if you're going out of like a felt
psychological necessity to work out five
times per week
so you don't lose your gains but like
you don't really want to go to the gym
but you feel like you need to
uh just chill out like you you don't
need to
yeah i used to live in columbus which is
very famously the
location of the arnold classic sports
festival
not a lot of people traveling in there
were skipping their workouts i can tell
you that for sure
a lot of people in the gyms that week
uh cool so moving on i think we've got
some uh some good questions
from our listeners um the first one
i am assuming is for me so i'm gonna
take that one
uh lane folks asked a question
uh preferred body hair
removal techniques uh he says he assumes
that a pro bodybuilder
would have some interesting insights a
pro natural
or a pro uh classic bodybuilder probably
would as well
yeah i was gonna say i'm gonna try not
to be offended
uh that just completely threw away half
of my professional athletic career with
the question but that's fine
um yeah so here's the thing about hair
removal
and greg i can see your chest hair
poking out through your
uh showing a lot of skin today i just
have really open uh neckline there
really plunging neckline on that
on that shirt but anyway you have no
no opinion on this topic for certain um
anyway so hair removal here's the deal
i've said this before i'll say it again
i can starve to death or near to death
in bodybuilding prep
it's fine it's not ideal but
it's kind of part of the game i hate
hair removal it is my least favorite
thing about bodybuilding by a mile
hair removal and the tanning process i
hate both of them so much so
uh you know body hair removal if you're
doing it for bodybuilding purposes some
people are like oh
shaving is annoying i'm going to use
like a chemical
strategy like like nair where you just
kind of
put it on and then you like just wipe
off your hair
uh i've heard some i've heard people i
trust tell
me not to do that for bodybuilding
because
uh some people their skin doesn't react
too well to it
and so then it you know there's all
sorts of like puffiness and redness and
that that's not what you want on stage
and
when when you have all those tanning
products for a physique sport
uh like sometimes the tanning product
doesn't want to stick to your skin very
well
like depending on i don't know
characteristics of your skin i don't
really understand how it works i
like i said it's my least favorite part
of being a competitive bodybuilder but
basically what you got to do is just
shave it
it's the way it goes you use like
shaving cream or you can use like
soap as shaving cream i think uh i'm not
an expert on this
i don't know but you just shave it and
it's it's a pain and it takes
so long and i hate it and then
i i yeah if i never had to
to do hair removal again then i never
would i probably
yeah it's just terrible you just shave
you get the
the razor that is gonna allow you to not
just completely tear your skin off and
just do your best with it
have a schedule though you don't want to
do it all at the same time that's a lot
of surface area do like
your arms one day and your you know
chest and abdomen a different day in
your legs the other day
that's the best i can do i assume you
have to get
assistance for your back right correct
yeah you're gonna have to get some
assistance
cool makes sense yeah i've had a lot of
people shave my back
in my life but yeah that's the best i
can do but
honestly my number one tip is uh for
body hair removal avoid it
if you if you can because it's not fun
yeah yeah i mean
outside of a sport where you have to do
it like bodybuilding or swimming
i just don't know why you would it's
awful it's terrible
uh moving on i've got a question here
from
mars marcis gretans
does that seem correct i suppose
so the question is why is there so much
controversy regarding
multivitamin consumption with many
evidence-based people
some people recommend against their use
others
recommend using multivitamins as an
insurance policy against micronutrient
deficiencies
under what circumstances would you
recommend their use is it worth taking
them
even if you're not deep into a cut and
probably not risking any serious
deficiencies well uh
honestly i'm more in the camp of
multivitamins being
a pretty low risk pretty
cost-effective insurance policy
against micronutrient deficiencies
is that a hill that i will die on no
if if you don't want to take a
multivitamin i'm very comfortable with
you not taking a multivitamin
like this is not a hobby horse topic
where i need
i feel the need to get multivitamins in
every household
but you know a lot of people with their
dietary choices are not
going through and carefully making sure
they're getting all of their
micronutrient bases covered uh some
micronutrients
especially you know people that are on
diets that exclude entire food groups
uh it can be easy to unknowingly kind of
disregard a micronutrient that you don't
think about much
you know so especially when you start
getting into some of the
less talked about minerals uh a lot of
them you just don't
think about it too much like when was
the last time you checked your manganese
intake
right or like your selenium intake yeah
you there's just a lot of micronutrients
that people just don't really think
about and some like food tracking
software is like a lot of times
you can't even find it in there and so
yeah
i just i don't really see the downside
of
if you're uncertain about your
micronutrient intakes especially if
there are entire food groups that you
don't consume
i just don't see i don't see why it
would be controversial
i think like the the controversy
controversy should
uh really only this is how the
conversation should go
uh hey uh do you think i should take a
multivitamin
i don't know do you have any concerns
that you're not getting all your
micronutrients
absolutely not i'm sure i'm getting all
of them cool then don't take it like
that that's a pretty straightforward
uh very defensible solution uh
to that problem but if you have doubts
and you're uncertain and you don't feel
like doing a full
nutrition audit and looking through
every possible
micronutrient and you know by the way
you know
some micronutrients you know they don't
absorb very well with each other or if
you take them and you don't have
something else in the meal it might not
absorb very well
and i mean a lot of multivitamins use
versions of particular micronutrients
that
do have poor oral bioavailability so
like a big one
a big one that i see um is like a lot of
them use
if they have like zinc and magnesium in
them they'll use like zinc and magnesium
oxide which have
which i think are the cheapest to
produce but have
something approaching zero oral
bioavailability like the
the uh chelates or chelates are
are much better are much better absorbed
so like
you you do have to deal with the
potential drawback of like poorly
formulated products
and you as the consumer probably don't
want to do
several hours of research to figure out
the oral
the oral bioavailability of every
vitamin and mineral in a particular
multivitamin
well but but also in in the food sources
that you're using you know so like
you might find that based on the label
content like oh yeah i got all the
calcium i need but
some of your food sources for calcium
had poor bioavailability
you know like so a lot of times
i yeah like i said i just think it's not
a terrible insurance policy but
if you don't want to take it like you
know then don't take it you could always
go get a blood test and see if you have
any notable
uh deficiencies or you know
even if it's not like a clinical
deficiency it could be subclinical you
could just have slightly
sub-optimal blood levels of a given uh a
given nutrient so
the one thing i would push back against
is that some people treat this topic
as if you know nutritional deficiencies
are a thing of the past and it's like oh
dude yeah we solved that when we started
adding stuff to like
lucky charms you know we said we
fortified all these foods
you know so unless you're going really
far out of your way to have an
incomplete diet there's no way you could
have
sub-optimal levels of certain
micronutrients
that is a thing i see us repeated often
and i just don't think that's accurate i
i think there are
many instances it's i mean it's not like
i don't want to be like uh
i don't want to sensationalize it and
act like yeah most people have just a
hugely problematic nutrient
insufficiency but
it's not that uncommon to see people who
have slightly sub-optimal levels of a
given micronutrient and might have a
slight benefit
uh from from correcting that so
yeah i i don't think it's like a
critical must-have supplement but i also
don't i don't get why it would be
controversial because
if you take it and you didn't need it i
don't see really much potential for harm
and it's not a a particularly high cost
supplement as far as the supplement
market's concerned so
um i i have seen people say like oh man
there's all these studies with like
vitamin d toxicity or
increased risk of this bad outcome with
high dose vitamin e
but i mean you look at the formulation
of a basic multivitamin multimineral
supplement
they don't have the types of doses that
you're seeing associated with vitamin d
toxicities or associated with you know
issues with super high dose vitamin e so
i think a lot of that
is um you know there are some true
statements out there that simply don't
apply to the typical multivitamin
formulation so that's my take yeah so i
i have two things i would add
um one is vaguely related so i'll
get to that second first thing though is
that i do
think that um one potential risk
of using a multivitamin is it could have
uh something akin to like a health halo
effect
where people assume like ah you know i'm
i'm
munching my flintstone vitamin every day
so my
my micronutrient intake is covered so
like
i really just don't need to worry about
food quality too much beyond that like
you know they instead of viewing it as
an insurance policy where there might
still be some
gaps that you're not aware of in an
otherwise good diet
some people may see it as like a
an insurance policy that allows them to
eat a
not very good overall diet and not have
to worry about things
and one i mean
i i do think that you're probably better
off
trying to get your micronutrients in
from whole foods if possible
and two like there are there are
benefits to
say fruit and vegetable intake that
aren't going to show up in like a
vitamin and mineral blood assay so um
you know for example earlier in this
podcast
trex talked about capsaicin and
capsaicinoids like they may have some
positive effects but like
they're not micronutrients that you're
going to get blood tests for
um the there's like a class of compounds
in brassica vegetables called
isothiocyanate
that have a lot of positive health
effects again
not classically defined micronutrients
you got you got polyphenols and
anthocyanins
in in fruits and berries
you know there's a lot of good [ __ ]
especially in
plant foods that uh aren't going to show
up
as vitamins and minerals and so you know
if you're
eating a generally good diverse diet
uh and and you think like yeah you know
i'm gonna take a multivitamin just to be
safe
i think that's totally cool i think if
you look at it from the opposite
perspective of like
hey i don't have to worry about the
overall quality
of my diet because i am taking a
multivitamin
uh i think you're probably gonna be
missing out on
a lot of other good stuff due to a uh
a faulty thinking pattern well yeah i
mean i certainly
agree with that and you know that's it's
kind of why
i frame it as an insurance policy
because like you know
i've got health insurance but you know
i'm not going too
crazy right like i don't want to need it
so like yeah i i
if you're if you're asking like hey are
multivitamins
a suitable replacement for eating good
foods then like
definitely not like they're like you
said there there are definitely
uh a lot of beneficial bioactive
compounds in a variety of different
foods that
that it would be ideal to get them from
from whole foods right uh
another thing to keep in mind is like
one of the biggest criticisms i see with
uh multivitamins is people be like dude
look at this study the total waste of
money i'm very upset i'm very pissed
like
my personal take is like if you didn't
need your multivitamin
i i kind of view that as the the good
scenario
not the bad scenario and so like a lot
of times they'll be like yeah we
you know we looked at uh
mortality in this big group of people
in a country where fortunately there's
high food availability and what do you
know the multivitamins didn't make
people live longer
in a big population of folks with
you know a lot of access to food that's
terrific
like that's a good thing that the fact
that people are
are getting adequate intakes uh you know
from their diet that's not a bad thing
so like i don't know i
some people look at that outcome and say
oh i had a very good balanced diet this
whole time and i'm upset about it
i don't see it that way yeah and one of
the
uh rhetorical things that you'll see
people say is they'll frame it the same
way as
a lot of other supplement discussions
like ah you're just flushing money down
the drain
it's like dude multivitamins are like
[ __ ] 10 cents a pill
like come on man yeah don't give me that
argument if you drink
more than a beer a month yeah like
come on man like yeah it's it's it's not
a high cost
dietary supplement compared to others
and you know we've got people out there
who take all sorts of stuff and
yeah i just i don't see where i don't
think it's interesting enough to have a
controversy i
think that's my general take no i i
agree
uh so that was the thing i had on
subject the
the thing that i alluded to that is
slightly off topic but i found it quite
interesting
uh is i came across an article a
couple weeks ago um discussing how
uh iodine deficiencies are apparently
making a comeback
for a couple reasons one is
um so uh historically like people would
consume
some degree of iodine in their water um
and and like the goiter belt in the usa
that that was largely associated with
just
the area of the u.s that had low iodine
levels and water
um and so like more and more
people are drinking like hyper filtered
hyper distilled water now
and so uh there's there's a decrease in
iodine intake from water
and the other thing like the thing that
really pretty much wiped out iodine
deficiencies in the us at least
was uh fortification of table salt with
iodine
but more and more people are shifting
towards fancy salt and so they're not
just using
you know the the good classic morton's
table salt with the really fine grains
and iodine fortification like more and
more people are using
um like kosher salt or like flaky salt
or whatever
uh that hasn't been fortified with
iodine so you know
i'm not trying to scare monger like most
people probably
still don't need to worry about iodine
deficiencies but that that was
um that was like a public health issue
that had been
basically eradicated in the u.s that is
uh starting to make a little bit of a
comeback and
previously it was largely associated
with poverty and now it's more
associated with affluence from people
drinking fancier water and using fancier
salt
um so i find that somewhat interesting
and as a as a practical thing you know
if if you don't if you don't want to
have to think about iodine
intake at all just eat seafood like once
or twice a month
uh or seaweed i mean seaweed has so much
iodine it's insane
uh and if you are someone who likes
fancy salt
i am among those people i have my my
diamond kosher for seasoning meat
uh and i have my flaky salt is my
finishing salt but
if i'm salting something where it's not
like
specifically to um like dry brine of
meat
or as like a finishing salt where
texture doesn't matter all that much
i still use just plain table salt if you
know i'm salting pasta water or
saltine water that i'm going to use to
make rice with
not a terrible idea to just use
plain old-fashioned iodine enriched salt
for salt applications where
the uh the actual texture of the salt
doesn't really matter because
table salt is still tastes like salt um
so yeah not not a terrible idea if
you're if you're a fancy salt
aficionado yeah i did some fact checking
uh because you know i mean the show is
rigorous
and so i looked up uh the the vitamin
that i use
because i i i'll be honest i'll be
completely transparent here i was
wondering when i said like
multivitamins are a low-cost
intervention i was like
am i kind of being an [ __ ] in saying
that
but i looked it up you could get uh
the vitamin i take a full year supply
for like 12 so like i said like
if you go out to a brewery tonight and
get two beers you just
you just got a year worth of
multivitamin costs
so when everybody kind of says that line
like oh dude that's such a waste of
money
dude it's like it that's like four cents
a capsule yeah it's
it's it is not by definition a huge
waste of money because
like i said it's a year supply for like
12 or 15 bucks
uh okay so moving on uh what's the next
one here
yeah uh so have a a question from reddit
from
reliefpitcher22 i believe
reliefpitcher22 is the same person who
previously asked a question uh related
to like
if you could build the ideal athlete for
a particular sport what would they look
like
and i wasn't paying attention to the
username and i said like
you know a baseball pitcher who's like
nine nine feet tall and has crazy long
arms
uh he he was very tickled by that
response uh because
he is a relief pitcher and the 22nd one
uh but anyway another question uh is
there much of a difference
in hypertrophy between doing straight
sets and having your last set to failure
versus
doing all sets at 8 rpe and reps
decreasing as you fatigue
so uh you know first thing
off the bat important to acknowledge uh
as far as i'm aware there's no research
directly analyzing this question
um and if there was
god have mercy on their soul if they
tried to do
a accurate and justifiable power
calculation
because if if there were to be a
difference between these two
interventions
you'd assume very small effect size
probably need like 400 subjects per
group
uh so yeah i don't think there's any
research on this
and and practically i don't think there
would be much of a difference
um based based on the research that i've
seen
uh and if you're interested in reading
about this and and the particular
studies more
you can just google stronger by science
effective reps
and the relevant research will be
linked and discussed near the end of
that article
but anyway based on the research i've
seen
there's nothing
the the specific details
of a set to make it sufficiently
challenging
to induce a robust hypertrophic response
it's not that
it's not like you're trying to thread a
needle to achieve
the ideal stimulus there
as long as the load isn't wildly too
heavy or wildly too light
such that you know a pretty challenging
set lands you somewhere between
about five and 30 reps give or take and
as long as you're within
i would say two or three reps from
failure uh
our colleague at mass mike zordos i
think would say like six or seven reps
from failure
for my money that seems a little bit too
easy but
uh whatever i i think as long as you're
within two or three reps from failure
you'll probably be fine
um so yeah in both of these scenarios
you know if you're doing
say three sets of ten and you're hitting
failure on the third set
you probably don't have that that much
more than three reps in reserve on the
first set
um and i don't think that you get like a
bonus from hitting failure on the last
set
compared to the other scenario of two
reps in the tank
on all sets i think fundamentally
it's the same training stimulus um
or the the training stimulus induced by
those two different approaches
differs too little to practically matter
for
the vast majority of people so uh
whichever one of those vibes with you
better
um feel feel free to go with that
uh functionally i think they'll they'll
have
this the same impact long term
yeah in my coaching uh working with my
one-on-one clients i basically do a
combination of both of these things
uh there are some exercises where i i
program out some straight sets and then
we've got like a
an auto regulated final set where we get
kind of close to failure
so not all the way to failure but i
usually tell them like hey leave
one or two reps in the tank now i've got
other exercises where
start to finish it's auto regulated uh
you know get as many rips
as as many reps as you can get so uh
i agree with you i don't think there's a
huge difference and really
my decision for which exercises
uh are are programmed a certain way it's
it's mostly logistical more than
anything
yeah i i agree wholeheartedly um
oh the other thing i'll add is for me it
might differ a little bit
based on whether you're talking about a
heavy actually
axially loaded barbell exercise versus
like
an assistance lift i don't know that i
ever want not ever
i don't i don't want people frequently
say squatting until they actually fail a
rep
yeah yeah so you know the the
yeah you know leave a couple reps in the
tank approach for
something like a squat maybe a deadlift
i think i'd opt
for that for for those types of
exercises
most other things i don't think it
matters too much if you don't want to go
to failure don't
uh or if you're cool reaching failure on
the last set
go for it so yeah i think that there's
like
a slight consideration for the exercise
you're talking about but
there are there also aren't that many
heavy heavy axially loaded exercises so
really we're just talking about squats
and maybe deadlifts yeah and with the
squat and the deadlifts sometimes i'll
use an approach where i'll
give straight sets until the final set
and for the final set
instead of saying hey take it to failure
i'll say leave
one rep in the tank or leave two or
leave three
uh but yeah i i'm with you i can't
remember the last time i told a client
bro just throw a load on your back and
go until you fall
like i've never told a client that but i
can't remember the last time i
really aggressively programmed uh you
know a deadlift
or squat set to to absolute true failure
it's it's not something i do that's one
of the reasons that i really like front
squatting in gyms with bumpers
because i don't like having to think
when the bar's on my back
like i just want to go for it uh and so
you know i i don't like having to stop
between reps on squats and thinking like
i think i got this next one but how much
do i trust my spotters like yeah
whatever
front squats with bumpers you can go to
failure it's great
because just dump it yeah if you if if
it gets too hard
the bar will simply fall and you'll be
fine uh
i think it's excellent all right um
so placidvlad asks
what are the biggest current myths
you're seeing on
the fitness instagram um
and i gotta say not many because when i
see people sharing myths
i tend to just unfollow them
but uh a general theme
that i've been seeing for the last
couple of months
uh not so much on instagram this is more
like in facebook groups
uh but you know this is something i've
been seeing for a long long time
the whole uh the general concept of
interconversion of fat tissue
and muscle tissue where you know people
say like ah
like i stopped working out because my
gym closed and all of my muscle turned
into fat
or like oh here are some some cool
workouts you can do to
turn that fat you gained during
quarantine into
hard lean muscle um
that's impossible there is no uh
there's no way to to physiologically
interconvert
adipose tissue and muscle tissue um
one one interesting little note i
suppose
is that uh myocytes like muscle cells
and uh adipose tissue cells
do actually derive from the same stem
cell line and
the the overall
uh nutritional and hormonal media
in your body is what determines whether
a mesenchymal stem cell is going to
differentiate into
uh a a myocyte or a
adipocyte so like you know
in the in the most basic
like at birth these cells have some
degree of
uh capacity to differentiate um
and like especially that's true like
during fetal development
but you know once you've got like a
mature myocyte it's not turning into an
adipocyte or vice versa
um so yeah i mean i
understand where that idea comes from i
think one of the reasons
like this is something that that my
parents talked about uh with me when i
got into lifting
um they were like ah man you're gonna
build all of this muscle and then like
when you get older it's just gonna turn
to fat
and i think i think that idea originates
from like
seeing professional athletes after they
retire
and i i think the explanation for that
is like oh they used to
play a sport professionally and work out
all the time uh
and then they stopped playing the sport
their caloric ex
yeah their caloric expenditure went down
they stopped training as much but like
for the past two decades of their life
they learned to eat like an athlete and
they probably still are and so
they're losing fat and gaining muscle or
they're losing muscle and gaining fat
but by
different physiological processes uh and
and vice versa i mean when people start
training
it's not uncommon at all to
simultaneously lose some fat and gain
some muscle
but those again are different
physiological processes
there's no interconversion between those
tissues going on
i'm sure 99.8 percent of people
listening to this podcast
already knew that but you know that
based on
the fact that a lot of people who had
previously been in the gym
were out of the gym for a long time a
lot of people who
have recently been out of the gym for a
long time are going back to the gym
i have seen a lot of muscle to fat inner
conversion discourse
uh and yeah that's that's a myth
yeah i don't think i really qualify to
have an opinion on this one i
i currently follow precisely 11
accounts on instagram and they haven't
been posting myths lately
but two of them are actually in this
very building at this point in time so
congrats to both of you i think your
content's been terrific
uh no myths so big stamp of approval
there
uh okay uh moving on to play us
out i'm really excited about this to
play us out segment
uh because i don't want to steal your
thunder i want you to take it from here
and just uh just do your thing with it
wait did didn't you have something last
time that we didn't get to
no oh all right you're uh
the stage is yours yeah yeah let's do
this so um
so i i recently joined a gym uh near my
house
uh i i'm still a member of
the power lifting gym that i've been
going to for a while but
you know now that i'm losing some weight
i'm going to be getting weaker
if not now eventually eventually
powerlifting training becomes
somewhat demotivating and you know i
just want to have some access to some
machines get a pump in
have a good time so i joined another gym
that
i joined it purely for the machines
and when i signed up they said hey
within the first month that you're a
member you can get a complimentary
fitness assessment i was thinking like
uh
i don't know i don't i don't really care
uh but then i got an email that said
and you'll get a 10 gift card i was like
okay that's
that's enough of a carrot that i'll at
least
check it out that's eight months worth
of multivitamins
yeah yeah um and and the thing is like i
know how this goes
like i know that this isn't magnanimous
uh
gyms make money commercial gyms make
money on personal training and members
who don't show up
um that that is the business model
um and so you know
they're trying to sell me on personal
training that's the only purpose of this
i knew it going in uh so i was mostly
just
intrigued i wanted to see like okay what
hard sell tactics
is this gym using i'm i'm interested to
see how this goes
so uh i show up for my complimentary
fitness assessment
and um we have the
briefest conversation imaginable about
what my goals are and what i want to
accomplish
um so i said you know my my main goal
currently is i'm trying to lose some
weight
uh it's going pretty well uh you know it
i at the time i was down 15 pounds from
where i started recently and about 30
pounds from my peak so
you know trying to lose weight but
that's currently going pretty well on my
own
um and as far as training goes i've been
in the gym for a long time power lifting
for 15 years
um and you know so i was
making it clear to them that i was going
to be someone who was pretty
who would be pretty challenging to sell
to so i wanted to see if that would
induce them to either sell harder or
realize that i was a lost cause and back
off
definitely went with the former um
so okay very very short conversation
less than five minutes later um
the the guy who was taking me through my
fitness assessment
asked if i'd ever worked out before
again after we'd exchanged maybe four
sentences of
discussion one of which is saying i'd
been powerlifting for 15 years
so clearly didn't listen at all uh you
know he he
knew what he wanted to put me through he
had a sales script
one of which like one of the questions
was asking me if i'd ever worked out
before so
already off to a very good start um
so let's see then we talked about
lifestyle
um i said uh i had a fairly sedentary
job but that
i'm pretty active uh typically walk 10
to 12 000 steps per day
typically either lift or play basketball
most days of the week
and i also said that i currently had a
broken wrist
so i couldn't grip any significant
weight and also couldn't take any
significant compressive force through my
wrist so
that's that's more information for him
told him like hey look i'm i'm fairly
active
can't do anything with my wrist those
are two additional pieces of information
for you
so we'll we'll circle back to that later
so
uh one of the first parts of the fitness
assessment was going to get a 3d body
scan
which was pretty cool i don't know how
much stock to put in it but
uh basically just stood on a platform
that turned around in a circle
and the um like
i'm pretty sure it was just using a xbox
360 console with the
like little vision thing that it had
built in um
but anyway uh did a 3d body scan
uh the the printout comes back uh it
said i was 26
body fat uh so he said like oh you're 26
body fat so uh you probably want to lose
some weight don't you
i was like dude i already told you that
[ __ ] five minutes ago
um so off to a very good start he said
the device measured you
uh or dem or measured your basal
metabolic rate at
uh 2344 calories and i said
huh measured interesting how how does it
measure my bmr
he said proprietary technology
i said interesting so
uh obviously a body scan cannot measure
bmr um it's i'm i'm sure it's purely
based
on height weight body comp age
uh anyway so i said oh proprietary
technology
interesting and he said okay yeah yeah
so based on this information
we can multiply your bmr by 1.2
to calculate your maintenance calories i
said oh interesting so
is it uh you know is that just a fixed
number it's
it's bmr times 1.2 for everyone to
calculate maintenance calories
he said yep and i said huh interesting
so again there there are various
multipliers based on activity levels
1.2 assumes that someone's completely
sedentary so for me that was very bad
advice
i had told him 10 to 12 000 steps per
day
generally either lift or play basketball
most days
my the correct number for me is probably
somewhere around 1.5
1.6 and the multipliers go all the way
up to about 1.9
for someone who's very active so uh
anyway
we're still less than 10 minutes into
this complementary session
uh and it's it's not going too hot
uh but you know it's fun so i i stick
with it
so um you know now now that we've
got my body comp he wants to see if i
can move well so we go to do the fms
the functional movement screen um
and and i told him like you know i
i basically wanted to get to the sales
pitch to see how that would go so i i
tried to
press fast forward so i tip my hand a
little bit like
at this point the guy doesn't know what
i do for a living so i kind of tipped my
hand and
implied that i know a fair bit about
what he's doing so i said like
yeah i've done the fms like i've put a
lot of people through the fms
here's what i'm going to score on
everything like let's just hurry up
he was like oh no no let's do it anyways
so
uh we do the fms uh
i learn for about the fourth time in my
life that i'm incapable of performing a
squat
which is always a fun and cool thing to
learn
his diagnosis was that my hamstrings
were too tight to squat
again not possible movement restrictions
and the squat
just cannot be caused by hamstring
tightness unless they're
so tight that you can't go through
activities of daily living so that that
was a cool thing to learn
um when we get to the push-up plank part
of the fms
i said i can't do that i have a broken
wrist that's too much compressive force
he said are you sure you don't want to
try just so we can get the full fms
score
i said yes
and you know i think it was just because
like he he had a scoring rubric for if
you put someone through
all of the fms things like oh [ __ ] what
do i do if someone doesn't
do one part of this uh so really tried
to get me to
to get in a push-up position with a
broken wrist
uh but i i stood firm i said no not
gonna do that
so anyway go through the fms learn my
hamstrings are too tight to squat
my shoulders are too tight to bench my
hips are too tight to do a deadlift
and he tells me and again keep in mind
i've already told him i've been
powerlifting for 15 years
he said if you really want to get
serious about this powerlifting thing
you may want a trainer to help you with
your mobility
uh and i said
i've i've been competing for a decade
and a half like i i can do these things
and he was like ah
well i don't know
so it's it's already completely off the
rails at this
point uh but we're most of the way
through so at this point he asks uh
hey i do you want me to put you through
a free workout
just so you can get a an idea of how
personal training here goes
and again i know what's going on here so
the the purpose of this if you're
signing up for a new gym and someone
offers to push you through a free
workout
it's twofold one it's a good sales
tactic you're rendering services for
free
and so then the prospective client then
feels
some degree of indebtedness to you so
they'll be more likely to
then pay for your services or at least
like an additional workout or two
because they're like ah
like you gave me something for free like
i i
feel uh some degree of indebtedness
uh and then two the other purpose for
for putting someone through a free
workout like this
is uh you want to intentionally just
trash them and make them feel super out
of shape
so they'll feel like they need a trainer
to get in shape um
so uh you know i i know that a high
intensity interval circuit is coming
that's not how i typically train i'm
braced for the worst but i i know what
to expect
um so he he sets up the circuit for me
uh and it was initially four exercises
which
was a rowing machine a kettlebell squat
a shoulder press and a deadlift uh
if you've been keeping track to this
point this was this was again like a
week after i broke my wrist
so i could row that was a bit iffy like
even just gripping the rowing thing was
somewhat iffy but i was like okay
like whatever i'm gonna play ball
because pretty much everything else was
completely out like i couldn't
grip a kettlebell to do kettlebell
squats uh
i couldn't i couldn't hold much more
than like i i couldn't deal with more
than about 10 pounds of compressive
force
for uh like dumbbell shoulder press
and i definitely couldn't grip any
meaningful amount of weight for
deadlifts
um so i i offered to just do it like
unilaterally like
i can just do one arm deadlifts i can do
one arm overhead press
um and he was like oh no no you can just
like
not do those exercises so i ended up
just doing a circuit of uh
rowing 500 meters as fast as possible
doing
30 bodyweight squats rowing 500 meters
as fast as possible
doing 30 bodyweight squats which like
dude to be clear no matter how good of
shape you're in that's gonna [ __ ]
trash you
um and to be clear i was absolutely
trashed at the end of it
um and so
you know he's at this point i think
feeling a little bit better about his
chances
to make a sell because i'm clearly
completely beat at the end of this i
said oh man you look pretty big do you
want to come back over to the table and
talk about training packages
i said nah man like i need to get back
to work
he said what sort of work do you do and
i said
i run a strength training education
company
and then you could just like see his
face drop he's like
god i just wasted all of my time and he
said oh uh
i'll see you around i guess so uh
i mean you tried to save him from that
though i did but
i tipped my hand with the whole fms
thing um
but yeah he he tried his best that was
never a cell he was going to make but
overall it was
a very negative experience but it's not
done yet
um i thought that was the end of the
story but no no
they had emailed me the results of my 3d
body scan so
at the gym all we talked about was uh
body fat percentage
and therefore my my uh
measured basal metabolic rate uh
but when the 3d body scan was emailed to
me
one it's a cool thing to have because
it's
nightmare fuel like uh you the
image you get looks like a putty monster
from mighty morphin power rangers which
is pretty cool
i made that my profile pick for a day um
and then also at the bottom of the 3d
body scan
um there was this like
there there was a continuum with like
risk level
and body fat percentage and it said like
ah 26
body fat uh that is a higher body fat
percentage
than at least 90 of
uh males your age that's
that's high risk um
and just like very like in your face and
alarmist like
very high body fat percentage very like
high risk
for uh bad things happening down the
line
and like i have a decent grasp of
normative data for body comp so i was
like
look 26 that's higher than i want to be
but i know for certain that's not above
the 90th percentile
for body fat percentage for men my age
like i knew that for certain
so i i looked up normative data and it
was like
70th percentile uh
no no so never mind i i confuse myself
with my notes
um so i i knew that uh obesity rate was
like
greater than 30 and a 30 bmi is supposed
to translate to about 30
body fat for men so i knew that it had
to be somewhere below the 70th
percentile
so i looked up normative data and uh 26
body fat for a male my age in america
that's 61st percentile so
higher than average but not
not like incredibly so it is 0.28
standard deviations from the mean
uh 90th percentile would be 1.28
standard deviations from the mean
so like even like not just the trainer
but like the print out of body comp that
they emailed me
was trying to scare monger me by an
entire standard deviation
which uh not great not great you you
would assume that
they actually load real normative data
into their body cop assessment um
so like overall uh
i enjoyed this greatly i thought it was
very fun
uh the whole the whole time i was just
thinking like
i'm doing this for podcast content um
and you know i i haven't been horde sold
in a while and i enjoy it because i just
like seeing what people do
um like being hard sold is one of my
favorite things cause
i'm gonna say no like i'm not gonna give
you money uh
but i just like seeing the tactics i
think it's a blast
um but this gave me
uh it hammered home for me
why people why so many people do
have bad associations with gyms
and exercise and personal trainers
because
you know i i know what i know like i
have the amount of experience that i do
going through that isn't going to make
me feel bad
um like i thought it was
it was mildly annoying at worst and very
funny at best
uh but you know were i not as
experienced as i am and as just like
physically confident as i am
i could see that being a very negative
and mildly traumatic experience because
if you had even just the littlest bit
of insecurity insecurity any
self-consciousness about being in a gym
setting that would have been a disaster
yeah because the whole thing is designed
to tell you that like
you're out of shape uh your mobility
sucks
your body comp sucks uh oh man we only
put you through a 30 minute workout and
you're already this [ __ ] tired you
lazy piece of [ __ ] you need a personal
trainer
like that that's what the whole thing is
designed to do
it's to give you pain points you didn't
even know
you had to convince you to sign up to
get someone to address those pain points
for you
um and it's it's not good like
i think it's fun most people wouldn't
uh if you're a personal trainer don't do
this
um the
there are so many positive reasons
that you can give people for exercising
uh exploiting fear and insecurity and
inducing
extra insecurity to then sell your
services
uh kind of gross don't like you
you can you can make good money in this
field
in far more ethical ways yeah and then
you know when you told me about this
off the air it was um
you know we operate online and we're
kind of
you know in the evident evidence-based
side of the fitness community and
i think sometimes hearing stories like
this is really informative because you
kind of forget what's going on out there
you know outside of the the little tiny
niche that that is very very research
driven and
you know uh yeah i just i i kind of
forgot that stuff like that happens in
the fitness industry
uh i don't know why i forgot but i did
i've just i've been in a little bubble a
little echo
chamber i guess and yeah it was just
sometimes you forget about this stuff
but it's it's important to remember
that a lot of people that is their
window into fitness like that is their
one
fitness interaction that they recall you
know people who
are not part of fitness or the fitness
community they they say oh i just moved
to a new area maybe i'll sign up for a
gym
and that is their window into the entire
world of what we do
which is unfortunate so if you are a
practitioner you know give people a
better window
into our little world make people feel a
little bit
a little bit more welcome and just
operate a little bit more ethically than
that
if you can absolutely so yeah that's uh
that is my to play us out segment all
right well
i hate to hear it you know i'm sorry
that you're totally unable to squat
but something that we can
we can work on uh i almost forgot to
mention
bulk supplements.com but i remembered
in the 11th hour here so that that's
going to be
that would have been a very
uncomfortable conversation if i forgot
to do that again so
one last reminder if you have any
dietary supplement needs
you head over to bulksupplements.com you
put in the code sbs
pod in all caps saves you just
really astounding huge amounts of money
uh
i i don't understand how they make it
work it's a five percent discount
uh they're just hemorrhaging their
profits but hey
capitalize on it take them up on it um
okay i think that does it for this
episode we'll be back
in a couple weeks with another one as
always thanks for joining us
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you